here my two batteries I have my problem
I and I wanted to be y is less than so
is that above the parabola or below it's
below good so what I've got is this
outside section here if you like okay um
I've got all these parts around yeah
these are all inverted commas below the
problem okay good then i have y is
greater than or equal x plus 2 now you
will notice you'll notice even though I
see the boundary is included y is
greater than or equal to X plus 2 I have
drawn it for starters I have drawn it
without including it and the reason why
is because you can see immediately
without me having done any work in
further than what I've already put on
see this piling here inside or I should
I say above the parabola that portion of
that's good morning y equals x person
soon that portion is already excluded
from the region can you see that because
it doesn't satisfy this green part that
I've shaded okay so it can't be included
so even though this whole boundary is
meant to be part of it well parts of
that boundary are out right so as a as a
rule of thumb you draw all your
boundaries as dotted lines you draw all
your points of intersection as hollow
circles and if you want to fill them in
later no problem okay but it's generally
a bit harder to draw them solid or draw
them filled and then rub them out after
the fact when you're like oh wait not
included okay so little lessons your
loan we want the straight line down and
my above or below the straight line I'm
above good so what I've got really is
i'm just going to do this in green I'm
above the line over here right so that's
over up here in the corner above the
straight line and then over here this
straight leg goes all the way down to
the negative okay so this was all fair
game it was for the parabola right and I
can go all the way down to here but I
can't go any further because I must
remain above that y equals x
too okay so doesn't just like stopped at
the access it keeps going okay now then
there are two things left ok firstly
I've already put the intersection points
on the intersection points are always
going to be part of their use of
information so you can see I just really
quickly computed the X values and then I
pop them into why can't us to get their
coordinates are they included or not now
I need to satisfy I've rubbed it up I
need to satisfy all the inequalities at
the same time right so if for instance
like I have this straight line I know
it's included right but the parabola is
not included ok so that means once you
see at least one of them being not
inclusive of the boundary all of your
points of intersection or the boundaries
are already excluded does that make
sense so one of the boundaries doesn't
doesn't do that so therefore none of
them can so I leave them as hollow there
is one extra piece of inflation I now
need to put on there which is that
having identified the right regions I
now have one more intercept right namely
this guy over here right had I be in for
instance above okay so so maybe I was in
here that could be impossible I wonder
how you change these inequalities in
order to get that region if I was above
here this intersect is no longer
relevant because not included in the
band room right but at the moment I do I
go right through it so I better put in
that that's negative two ok and that
looks like it you're happy with that any
questions right now when you have a look
at three you can see there's more
boundary lines coming in i have three
boundary lines right let's just quickly
talk through it one of them is a circle
oh wait I'm not finished you missed is
something I missed when I missed
good yes I i I'm inclusive of on this
this battery right you make sure you
finish it off ok so I'm not increasing
up the intersection points but outside
they're all right for instance this guy
here you see that right can you see it
is below the parabola tick is on the
line or above that's that's what it
means on it or above so it's ok and at
the same in the same way down here this
part is also included so that becomes a
solid line right don't picked it up ok
we're sleep in his work that's right
let's have a go this one now we've not a
circle and two straight lines yes ah
this part in here doesn't satisfy that
inequality right it's not on it's not
below the parabola it's above the
parabola so therefore this part of the
line isn't actually power of the
boundary and if I took a point like say
that um that would be 02 right 02 if I
put it in wouldn't satisfy this end is
the same time it would only satisfy that
one right so therefore since it doesn't
satisfy this because when you put it in
two is not less than zero right there
for this section of the battery is not
included ok so that's why it stays body
good question